à une heure du combat la concentration
règne dans les loges victoire pitot
s'apprête à affronter la serv sarah
marge à novik une adversaire coriace
expérimentés un combat qu'elle a préparé
avec son père boxeur amateur qui la
coach depuis son plus jeune âge voilà
comment s'est elle avait 7 ans était bon
ce que pour s'amuser à l'époque puis
petit à petit à partir de 13 ans a
commencé à devenir plus sérieux à 14
années passées amateurs l'année d'après
à les rentrer en équipe de france et
puis après tout parcours amateur
championne d'europe championne du monde
elle était championne de france et puis
elle a fait le choix de passer
professionnel et c'est des années des
années de travail
et puis on espère que ce sera qu'une
étape on va aller encore plus haut un
travail payant puisque lasarroise a
imposé son style dès les premiers rendre
plus agile et plus vive que son
adversaire victoire a franchi le palier
du haut niveau une fierté pour son
entourage seront morts
pas de contact avec des jeunes filles
qui véhiculent des grosses valeurs des
bonnes valeurs pour le sport féminin
déjà et puis dans le sport de la boxe
proprement dit et puis et c'est une
pique qui s'est assez scabreuse une
fille entre guinée de la raison de sa
mort jamais on l'imaginait qualification
coins de france championne une ceinture
mondiale aujourd'hui donc c'est vraiment
une fille qu'il faut qu'ils prouvent
qu'il faut soutenir victoire en portent
la ceinture wbc francophone avec ce
combat un joli cadeau d'anniversaire
pour celle qui fêtera ses 22 ans ce
lundi 19 avril est déjà une envie de
viser plus loin
maintenant que j'ai ma ceinture a en
main je vais essayer de savourer un peu
cette cette victoire j'ai d'autres
objectifs sur le long terme comme un
championnat d'europe même un championnat
du monde mais pour l'instant je vais
savourer cette victoire et pour le reste
on verra après en parallèle victoire
continue d'exercer son autre profession
accompagnatrice socioéducatif pour
jeunes décrocheurs avant de pouvoir
décrocher d'autres titres internationaux
sur le ring